(moaning/screaming)
(moaning continues)
Someone's moaning up a storm out there. Hello everybody...
my name is Markiplier, and welcome to Spooky Cellar.
Alright, you can shut up now!
Any second now!
So, this is... probably the scariest game in
(thunder clap) Wh-hi.
Figure: Oh, good, you're awake! Oh, looks like they're already here.
Figure: There's no time to explain
FIgure: I need YOU to get in the cellar.
Okay?! What does that even mean?
Wh...(sighs) Wasd to walk. Okay, alright, I'll walk.
(laughs) I didn't know this was literally the game "No Time to Explain." Oh, it is...
Dark...
Okay, is that a flashlight?
Oh, it is... Space to jump?
(uncomfortable laugh) You're just gonna throw me right into it! Now, this might be...
the scariest game you ever see today. So buckle up, turn up your volume in your headphones,
turn out the light, and get ready to have the pants spooked off of you.
Because it's about to get dank. And it's about to get dark. And it's about to get spooky. Why do I need to sprint?
Why would I need to sprint?
Oooooo. What is that?
Nothing. Absolutely dick-diddly.
(surprise) Oh, hey!
(uncomfortable laughter)
Even down-darker-deeper. Oh! Floor 1!
(squelching)
I don't like that at all...
Okay. "No hope."
Yeah, no joke. Okay. Alright, well, whatever's down here,
it's not gonna be a match for me.
So it might as well give up, go fuck itself...
...and get out of my face before I even get close to it.
(growling)
Hi?!
What did I just see?!
OH, HI!
(scared battle cry)
Okay! Alright! That's not OOkay.
That's not okay!
(growling/panting) Hey. Hey. Hey. Hey, what are you doin' over there?
(surprised laughter) Wh...
What was that?
Why am I down here with it? Why did I need to come down into the cellar...
...when I was perfectly fine upstairs? Oh! Is this another way down?
(high-pitched) OOOHHH!
(confidently)I think I'm winning!
Not a hundred-percent sure, but I think I'm winning.
Oookay. What did I pick up?
(metallic screeching)
Oh, I picked up keys so that I could open that. I know that slinky-sounding keys...
So you're just...
Not gonna explain whatever the Hell was glowing in the darkness over there?
There was two burning eyeballs?
And its giant, luminescent body?
And its... rather pungent odor?
You weren't gonna say anything about that?
Am I supposed to be looking for something?
Am I supposed to be finding something?
Is there something in the darkness that I need?
And if you KNOW...
Tell me RIGHT NOW before I punch you in the dick!
Anybody?
If you even HAVE a dick. Your big, round body didn't suggest anything to the "dickest" nature.
So I'm gonna assume that's a "No," and I'm gonna carry on my way.
HELLLLLOOOOO!!?
See, I can't get a bearing on where I am
because it's just a buncha... of convoluted hallways with no end !
If I know my thing about--
(roar) OOOHH
HI, THERE'S MORE THAN ONE OF YOU!
THAT'S a new predicament that I have to deal with
and I can't sprint for very far because I'm out of shape!
I ate too many doughnuts over at CAAMMPP!
(huffing, growling)
Okay, aright, you can stop huffing and puffing in my ear! It's NOT gonna do you any good!
I cannot sprint for NOTHIN'.
(laughs) I...this is like... this is like a...
this like a... BASEMENT or somethin'.
It's like a spooky cellar.
(mumbles) alright, I think I'm okay.
(mumbles) I don't where I'm supposed to be going!
This, it all leads into nothing.
It's just a whole lotta NOTHING.
(Mark turns into a prepubescent boy) Man, if I didn't know any better...
...I'd say that I'm running in CIrCles.
Well, pfft...
Found my way back to the beginning of the map. That is good for me.
At least now I know that I'm making absolutely no progress,
So I should just bend over and kiss my ass good-bye.
OH, hello!
(metal clattering)
I need a key, that is obvious to me.
(monotonous) Ooohh, happy day. I'm full of glee.
(quietly) alright, ok.
So I gotta find a key.
It was PROBABLY in somewhere that I've been before but I didn't see it
because I didn't know I was looking for one, whatthehellisthatSOUND?!
Well, la-dee-dee, okay. Alright.
Well, if we're just gonna be like that, then I'm just gonna ssuuuuuu.....ck somethin'.
Hey, wait a minute! (laughs) Wait! I've solved the conundrum!
(metallic clattering)
(mockingly) I seem to be on the other side of the fence now.
I guess that means I'm doing just okay!
(laughs)
Nothing, ain't nothing gonna be bothering me no how, no way.
How you guys? You guys being bothered at all no way no how?
So, obviously this game wasn't supposed to take itself too terribly seriously. It's kind of a ridiculous concept
It's kinda silly because the enemies... aren't exactly...
...the most threatening of sorts.
BUT!
At least Grandpa was nice to me upstairs.
I don't know why he shoved me in this dark, dank cellar filled with MONSTERS,
but hey, I can always assume that he's looking out for the best for me.
(mumbles) Man, this is gonna be flip-dicking-impossible.
(mumbles) I have--
(snarl)
Bbb... Butte--
(manly scream) Oh...
(gross squelching)
{Don't you smirk like that. You know you messed up, even if it was a cheap jumpscare.}
Well...
If that's how you're gonna be, huh? Okay, alright!
I'll try again? (metallic screeching)
I don't know if you're randomly generated, or if I have to find a very specific exit.
ah WOAH. Hi, friend.
Ohhhooo...kay, let's NOT do that. Let's not dance this dance.
I can't go anywhere. I'm crapping my pants.
HOkay! Well...
(groan of relief)
Hey, I thought you changed your mind!
(sucks in deep breath) bRUHAAHHH
(someone slamming their fists on a piano) (more gross squelching)
At least I explode blood all over the screen...
OOO!
Wh-I saw the butt-ass of something that I didn't like!
And that is a very rare occurrence--
(roar) HOKAY! I SAW THE FRONT-ASS END OF SOMETHING THAT I DID NOT LIKE!
(angry gasp) hHEY!
Yeah, I thought it was gonna be a dead end--
ooooo...
(song-like) I think we got away from ittt!
(manly scream)
OH MY GOD! OKAY! ALRIGHT THEN!
IF YOU'RE JUST GONNA DO THAT TO ME
THEN I'M JUST GONNA PUNCH YOU IN THE DICK!
IF YOU EVEN HAVE A DICK!
Oooh, it's right behind me, isn't it?
Kay, maybe not.  Oh...
Alright, we're fine.
I mean, we're not FINE because I can't find the frickin' way outta here.
At least, I'M fine.
I feel fine.
I look fine.
DAMN... I am fine.
(roar) WOAH, WOAH, DON'T DO THAT!
(incredulously) DON'T DO THE ROAR!
Jeez, what kind of T-Rex-ass roar was that?!
(snarl)
(mockingly) Alright, Mr. Attitude over there.
Eh, you ever just have a bad feeling crawling down your spine...
...as if you know some horrible monstrosity is lurking
around every corner?
oooOOOOOooo!
(creak)
Never mind! Those were the pleasant tingles of success!
I thought I was gonna--
(screams)
OH, GRANDMA! GRANDMA, GRANDMA NO!
NO I DON'T WANT THE COOKIES--
(moan)
(Mark screams)
(death scream)
(more squelching)
Alright...
If that's how we're gonna be... then I see--
(more manly screaming)
(laughing) Fucking God damn it. Why?
Why right out-- OH SHIT!
I'M FUUUCKED!
HEY, GRAANDMA!
(weird moaning)
WH--
...okay...
This seems to be a predi-- PFFT!
Nee (mocking) I'll just poke my head out. Maybe I shouldn't find me flien--
Wh-- (blows raspberry) Maybe I shouldn't talk out my ASS
before I actually-- Ooooohh...
I'm fuucked.
(weird laugh)
You better not come around this corner. I'm naked!
You wouldn't want to see anything about that, right?
Oooo, yes, you would. Okay
So, I just got to find my way out of here...
I just gotta keep an eye out...
for the cellar door.
And when we find the cellar door, that's when we know we're gonna be able to esca--
(growl) OOHP...
nnNO
nnNNOHO
No, no, no, no.
no, no, no, no.
Uh oh! No no n-- UH OH!
Is that Grandma? Oh, I have a feeling that is GrandMA!
Gran-moo-millie? Oh.
OH! It's NOT! It's a comforting BARREL...
of FIRE!
Maybe I can throw myself in it
so I wouldn't have to subject myself to anything that's happening over here.
What is THAT?
Nothing.
Great. I'm glad.
Okay. I don't know where I am.
WH-OH!
Grandma, no. Please, Grandma, no.
Grandma, no, no, no. Grandma, NO!
GRANDMA, NO!
(moan)
Grandmaaaa... What have I told you the-- AEHH!
Nice lip! AHH
Well that's not good.
I'm fuuuubbed.
I'm flubbed.
Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo!
Run, run, now! This is bad!
Hey! Grandma! No! No! No! No!
OooohhhHHOOOO
How did I survive? (nervous laughter)
(quietly) okay... alright. whatever.
(panicked panting)
OH!
I've made it.
Great!
I am so glaaaaaddd.
(voice crack) What the fuck? I didn't think this game was actually gonna be scary!
Geez.
The way it was advertising itself just made it seem like
it was just this ridiculous horror game and I was gonna play it and be like
"Yeah, look at how stupid it is!"
Geez, didn't know I'd be screaming for my life the whole time.
Yeah, well, whatever. Best to get my screambox a good exercise
every once in a while.
(groans) I can't see nothing.
Ohp!
Grandma! Ohp...
Oh, Grandma! Hey!
Woah, woah. Very stuck grandma.
Okay, alright, goodbye!
Yee, yee, yee!
Nooooo! Noooor!
NO, n--! NOOI!
Noi! Noi.
No, Grandma, stop. Stop, Grandma!
Grandma, that's enough!
Grandma, your animalistic sense of dread, it's just not... welcome here!
(scream) What the FUCKING...
FUCKING HELL?! Oh my GOD!
(laughs)(voice crack) My voice! AH! I am very much puberty!
(high-pitched) OkAY! ALRIGHT! WELL THEN!
I think I'm gonna end that one there.
So that is... Pfft. That is a Spooky Cellar
The Spooky Cellar is ridiculous, but scary.
So, if you wanna check it out for yourself, I'll provide a link in the description.
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below
And if you have other horror games that you want me to play, let me know them, as well.
(outro music starts)
Thank you, everybody, for watching. And, as always, see you
In the next video. Buh-bye!
(chill AF outro music plays)